welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss
oh and I'm Jessica Clemens oh my God I
wasn't ready for it I was drinking out
of my great merchandised mug I love it
and we together are Jerica and we are
breaking down Daredevil season one
episode four in the blood in our
Daredevil re-watch series The Road to
born again and this video is brought to
you by Squarespace more on them later
we're gonna start again right now with
episode four and let me get you into it
after last episode's brief introduction
to the man at the top this week we get
to see more Wilson Fisk and he
definitely isn't your average MCU Baddie
in the blood gives us some backstory on
more than just one antagonist though we
open on which I assume is utkin udkin
prison in severia eight years ago
Anatoly one of the Russians in the fist
crime circles dragged down a hallway and
thrown in a cell with his brother
Vladimir this episode opens and closes
with Anatolia in rough shape but while
the opening presents the Rock Bottom as
a jumping off point to greater things
the ending does not uh it doesn't it
doesn't at all and it's horrific okay so
Vladimir is presented here as the
tougher of the two brothers even though
he looks like he's younger than Anatoly
and the same stubbornness and
determination that causes him to pry or
rib bone from the deceased cell made to
use as a makeshift knife is what
ultimately leads to his brother's death
later on oh God he also has various
tattoos on his arms and chest we see
them on both the brothers along with a
lot of the other Russian crime mobsters
and one of them is actually the ten
rings on Vladimir he's got some Cree
text shout out we're now learning oh my
God that's true that's true he has Cree
Tech literally shouted out he doesn't
know yet well he'll never know but
eventually he's like Jack and Lost
getting a tattoo that he has no idea
what the characters mean oh my God he's
stupid the sky tattoos that are
displayed indicate that they're made men
in the Russian mafia these guys were
into some shady Shady business even back
in the day Anatoly says this
[Music]
stuff foreshadowing his fate at fisk's
hands but right now Vladimir is
optimistic as he grabs a second rib bone
from poor Alexi God stop doing this for
his brother to use in their escape oh
God here's another clip
privilege
and I love this in the subtitles Kings
is capitalized but these two make a
great mistake in their choice of
partnership when they get to America
because there's only one room at the top
for one king now this show could easily
have made the Russians your usual under
developed thugs you know of the
tracksuit variety whose only motivation
is to do the crime get the money but
Daredevil ain't your average superhero
show my friends and by letting us in on
some of the brothers backstory it serves
to humanize them a bit and we understand
why later on it's so hard for Vladimir
to go to fist to ask for help and why he
sends his brother instead these aren't
the kind of Russians who just get
shrunken and eaten by owls at the end of
the show we get to know them and we got
two Hell's Kitchen present day and we
see how these once Fearless Russians are
now afraid of the Man in Black who's
making business hard for them by
throwaway bodies onto the hoods of their
newly acquired cabs Claire is still in
hiding and still playing cut man to Matt
and you gotta wonder if she takes
insurance or if she just gets paid in
Long smoldering looks uh I'd happily
take that payment if we're talking about
Charlotte Cox but she tells Matt this
you really needs to get some kind of
body armor or something
slow me down too much so will a bullet
uh yes this foreshadow's Matt's eventual
suit and fisk's body armor being the
thing that saves him in the end for
anatoly's nice swipe Claire and Matt do
some flirting and classic Daredevil
fashion because as we pointed out he is
a boy and this dude just cannot
help himself that's why you keep ending
up here oh maybe I just like to sign
your voice clear Chucks his shirt at him
and he catches it with one hand just
like he did with that brick in
Spider-Man no way home the one-hitted
grab the second coolest power after
listening so prohaska's kitchen cabs are
having the signage switch to Villa's
taxi to indicate that they are under new
leadership ever since his running with a
bowling ball in Slavic lore Bellis is
the god of the underworld after the rise
of Christianity he became identified
with the devil but really foreshadowing
a certain devil of Hell's Kitchen who is
going to be raising some hell in this
Village Taxi garage later this episode
yeah so Wesley stops by for a visit to
tell the Russians that Nobu and GAO are
pissed with them because they haven't
handled the one man in Black oh Will
Smith
she had an iron suit or a magic hammer
maybe that would explain why you keep
getting your asses handed to you I'm
pretty sure he's talking about a
different guy with a hammer not this one
this is obviously yet another reference
to the Avengers this time Iron Man and
Thor after telling the Russians not to
use this name Wesley's eyes twitch when
Vladimir uses it again dude is
absolutely gonna regret that he said
that trust me Vlad you'd much rather
just deal with Wesley on him on his own
do not deal with do not deal with this
so Wesley leaves if Vladimir tells
Anatoly that the reason Fisk doesn't
want anyone to say his name is because
it would reveal that he's just a man but
when Anatoly fights Fisk later and
slashes at him with a knife he is
wearing body armor which gives the
illusion that he has supernatural
abilities so again Vlad is definitely
gonna come to regret downplaying what a
threat Fisk actually is we find out that
the man Matt dropped off the roof two
episodes ago is named Simeon and he's
currently in a coma at Metro General the
hospital where Claire Works Karen meets
up with Ben Uric to ask what he thinks
about the NDA the union Allied lawyer is
trying to get her to sign and scene
takes on and Master an apprentice Vibe
right off the bat the old grizzled
veteran and the new optimistic rookie
feeling each other out you've pretty
much brought down the Italian mob back
when I was in diapers whatever happened
to that reporter Mr Urich
and a hell of a lot less stupid so the
Russians visits an end at the hospital
and he is in bad shape you gotta admire
the fact that Daredevil isn't afraid to
show the actual damage aftermath of a
superhero ass kick and the brothers
injected him in with epinephrine to wake
him up and he has got to be in a lot of
pain they ask him about the man who did
this to him and he says yeah
[Music]
the first time we hear someone referred
to Matt by this moniker Simeon tells him
about Claire and the two Russians break
into her apartment she's obviously not
there but porcentino comes to the door
and gets door Tripper information this
kid's having a bad week yes and we
finally see Wesley and Fisk together
that we haven't got an entire scene with
Fisk the main villain of the Season
until almost halfway into episode 4
which is insane it is the first season
it's more reason why this show is
amazing Fisk and Wesley talk a little
business in the car and then Fisk
arrives at Vanessa's gallery
you stay with the car
sir
to this alone Wesley is so crushed that
he's not invited on this courtship
attempt and you can't help but feel bad
for this guy for just a little bit he
just wanted to play wingman to his best
friend his best his best man his bestie
this talks with Vanessa and this scene
really lulls the viewer into the false
sense of security with him before the
end of the episode pulls the rug right
out underneath you how are you enjoying
rabbit in a snowstorm
I hung it in my bedroom
it's the last thing I see every night
that's either very romantic
or very sad yeah the viewer is thinking
that with his soft-spoken nature to
strive on her ability maybe he's not as
bad as all the others have made him out
to be up until this point now this wears
black here while Vanessa wears white a
color palette that continues throughout
the series when they are together and as
he stands in front of the painting with
a mix of Reds he stands out whereas she
Blends in against the white wall he is
out of place but she is in her element
making him seem even more vulnerable In
This Moment the red painting also looks
a lot like what Matt sees when he
describes his world on fire I wanted to
thank you for it
personally
is there anything else I can help you
with no but I
yes I was actually wondering if you care
to join me for dinner notice how Fisk
approaches as he thinks sir but when she
seemingly dismisses him he falls back
it's like a little boy gutted from
slight rejection before regrouping and
asking her to dinner just a cool bit of
acting from Vincent D'Onofrio Vanessa
turns down his offer to dinner but when
fist goes to leave she seems surprised
that he gave up so easily she clearly
wants him to flirt a little bit but
again he's out of his element in the
criminal World he's always in command
but here he's thrown off his game she
tells him that a man once offered to buy
every painting in the gallery if she'd
go out with him here it is
can be bought
I am that woman that wants to be bought
this charms Vanessa though and she and
she agrees to date after the two of them
hold eye contact something Matt clear
did earlier when they were flirting this
episode shows a lot of parallels between
Fisk and Matt and we'll get into it even
more later the two of them introduce
themselves Vanessa
Wilson knows how Fisk hesitates before
he responds uneasy with anyone knowing
his true lonely self which serves to
humanize him a bit loliness and Vanessa
into a false sense of security regarding
who this man actually is so we jump to
Claire and the cat she's allergic and
very mean too
hit you little bastard this cat knows
something is up as he searches room and
meows a slightly tense Claire pops a
Benadryl and we see something outside
her fire escape moving around past her
curtains just look to the right clear
it's Vladimir and anatoly's men would
then cut to foggy and Matt leaving the
Third Precinct Police Department the
lanterns outside are green the reasoning
behind this green light has evolved into
the NYPD precincts normally have two
green lights hung outside the entrance
to symbolize the watch is present and
Vigilant foggy tells Matt did I tell you
my mom wanted me to be a butcher a story
he's told plenty of times later in
season three we'll get a ton of glimpses
at Nelson's meets foggy's family-owned
butcher shop so he really could have
been cutting his own brisket or whatever
and again foggy is only in the game for
the money mentions hating being broke
again and comparing the rate of a
butcher to what they're doing as lawyers
then Matt's burner phone rings the one
Claire can use in case of emergencies
when he picks up it's revealed the man
we saw in the fire escape has made his
way into Clara's home and drags her away
scratching at the floor and trying to
escape this scene is horrifying it is
horrible I hated watching it and a
reminder that Daredevil only gets more
Grim from here on out it's like watching
that scene and taken but like 10 times
worse because it's not uh Liam Neeson
also have to point out not every cab is
owned by the underground criminal ring
but this one may be though we're seeing
the side of the cap that doesn't have
Bella's taxi on it there's another shot
of a different taxi cab that is operated
by Bella's taxi that looks absolutely
identical so foggy maybe getting into a
car he has unknowingly very closely
connected to and is owned by an
underground criminal ring he could have
died there's a lot of opportunities
foggy could have also died but this one
is very important Matt speeds declares
house tossing his Cane directly into a
trash can and Parkour in his way to
Claire's apartment which is legitimately
insane because he must have memorized
the layout of where to jump and where to
latch onto she's not there but he finds
her phone on the ground and that cat is
still at large but remains innocent in
my eyes
yeah Matt either memorized the layout or
he's just hearing the ghosts of all the
people who tried to parkour over this
who died or a whispering jump here jump
there don't jump here
just all the Michael Scott and Andy
Bernards are like don't expect the same
mistake we did so Matt opens a window
and begins listening to the sounds of
Hell's Kitchen like he did in the first
episode to find that boy through the den
of casual chats car hordes a busy New
York City hustle and bustle he makes out
a pair of men speaking Russian and Matt
unmistakenly hears the name Santino in
their conversation and you know he feels
that guilt he's like I'm sorry I had to
bring that boy into this the Russians
have closed their trunk with Claire in
the back and drive off Karen is now in
an auction house her plan is to get any
information on the union Ally and this
place is auctioned off all its
liquidized equipment she looks
incredibly sketchy with a notepad at an
auction house not bidding at all he
thinks it would be like get the hell out
of here additionally she's sketching
people's faces because she doesn't know
their names which seems even more
literally sketchy thank God man yurik is
there to assist this small piece of
advice
but they aren't bidding either spend the
next dollar raising your paddle win
something one of the smaller Lots Ben
didn't know she'd be there but was
trying to get any information he can get
as well we're gonna get back to the
video in one second but I gotta tell you
about Squarespace not only are they
making it possible for me to do this
video but they could be making it
possible for you to do honestly whatever
you want to do online that's because
Squarespace makes it easy to make an
awesome website that lets you engage
with your audience and sell anything you
need your products content you create
even your time Squarespace is the
all-in-one platform for building your
brand and growing your business online
if you're making videos Squarespace can
help Squarespace can help you create Pro
level videos effortlessly this
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales but hey maybe making videos
isn't your thing because you're more of
a social media buff well no problem you
can display posts from any profile you
want on your website and automatically
push website content to your favorite
social media channels so your followers
can share it too no matter what you're
doing squarespace's analytic tools will
help you learn where your traffic and
sales are coming from and so you can
improve your website and build a
marketing strategy based on either your
top keywords or most popular products
and content so head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain then we
jump to Bella's cap service the home
base of their Shady operation this is my
favorite part of the shop the Russian
half nude portraits of models on the
wall Very car shop mentality not a
family-friendly place to leave your kid
playing his game boy
don't leave your kids don't leave your
kids at car shops don't leave them at
car shops there's gonna be weird news
a trunk and again
struggling their arms to survive the
Netflix Daredevil just gets so dark Matt
finds Santino a little bee nut and Matt
raises glasses to show him his face the
way he raised his mask in a previous
episode so the kidnapped little boy
wouldn't be scared he began speaking to
Santana in Spanish and finds out the
name of the taxi service I took Claire
and he's off again into the night
Meanwhile we're taken to I'm sorry if I
pronounce wrong brazi Brazier Brazier
this is a real place in New York City
and it unfortunately closed in 2015 once
Daredevil dropped but Brazier Brazier is
French for Brewery which is funny
because Vanessa and Fisk are going there
for Italian on that date a waiter pours
some wine for fish to taste Fizz
confesses he doesn't really know wine
and we know it's because he comes from
humble beginnings new money Fisk says
he's been to a preoccupied today and he
rubs his cufflinks we'll get into why
these couplings are so important on our
road to born again but remember we got
super Eerie close-ups of them in the
last episode yes they're his horcruxes
Vanessa and fist begin talking about
Hell's Kitchen mainly how Fisk wants to
change it for the better Boo for people
like Vanessa he makes a comment about
the city being part of him that it was
in my blood the title of the episode
then they cheers to making a better
place of Hell's Kitchen this episode
frames Matt Murdock and Wilson Fisk has
two sides of the same coin both hometown
boys who were defined by their traumatic
events in their childhood who now want
to clean up their City although their
means and methods vary they're really
not so different this episode shows
they're both capable of violence and
vulnerability lawlessness and love a
psychologist would tell you fisk's true
intentions and motivations are not in
fixing the city the cufflinks and his
goals are tied to the same event and are
like his like Nexus event it's like his
next it always has to happen in order
for him to do whatever he's doing and
the couplings are his horcrux yeah
that's right they're they're the key
they're the horcruxes they're like the
activation button they're everything you
really could just have a pair of
cufflinks walking around with like just
floating in the air we would know that
it was still Wilson fist I'm telling you
go go gadget but Dr claw I'll get you
next time devil of Hell's Kitchen Next
time
so the Silence of the last scene is
completely shattered as we cut to clear
bloody and beaten ah she isn't one of
the people like you Fisk was talking
about apparently they are beating her up
to get information on Daredevil his name
specifically and Claire knows the fake
name he gave her and still Bill refused
to share it with the Russians after
being beaten up and tortured she is what
Hell's Kitchen needs the women in the
show are putting their lives on the line
for the city with no powers absolutely
none they're not even good listeners
ah yeah what how dare they how they are
I think Claire is a good listener so
Sergey then tells Claire this this gives
me no pleasure it really doesn't but I
have been given a job to do so please
answer the questions that I was told to
ask
I will begin breaking you which feels
right out of Rocky Ford doesn't it then
Daredevil evens a playing field by
turning off the lights now he's clearly
outnumbered but remember he fights just
as well in the dark and these guys
clearly don't the Russians decide to
turn on the cap lights so the yellow
beams bounce off the people in the
cement so the DP having the time of
their lives setting up this shot the
orange from the street entrance the blue
from the emergency lights the yellow
from the street light additionally
notice the light bouncing off the ground
they had to make the floor wet to do
that this is movie Magic I'm obsessed
with these things I eat it up Knowing
damn well the lights were turned off on
purpose and the most villainous laugh
cleared Chuckles and tells them to ask
Daredevil his name themselves and cue
the beat downs keep in mind all these
people Daredevil begins beating up drop
their guns it allows the other men to
even pick up the guns but Daredevil
never picks them up because guns are
beneath him and he's better than that
he's even making noise in different
areas to distract them as he picks them
off one by one he's like a cougar in the
night in the midst of Daredevil trying
to teach Sergey a lesson Claire swings
the metal bat he used to scare her
directly across his head and as a doctor
I'm sure she knows she did some immense
damage but that doesn't matter right now
she's upset angry scared Shook and all
those emotions are coming back as
adrenaline slips away and she breaks
down into Daredevil's shoulder as he
Comforts her and it's so heart-wrenching
I ate it I don't like it so we're back
at the Square Diner where Karen and Ben
are meeting after the auction Karen put
3500 on some old office equipment and
build it to Nelson and Murdoch it's
revealed that the former Union Allied is
buying back their own equipment he gets
a backstory to Uric here but just a very
small amount Karen mentions an article
he wrote about a woman in which he
responds that the woman had the worst
fate marrying a workaholic that never
appreciated her speaking about himself
now I know the Beast storyline feels a
little dull in retrospect to Kingpin and
Daredevil gruesomely killing people but
you know it all makes sense especially
at the end of this season Karen is the
one who sucks Uric back into the
Intrepid investigator reporter life and
therefore when he is ultimately killed
she'll have that under conscience
something that is underscored with the
sound design of this scene Jessica did a
great job talking about the sound design
last episode here notice there's some
police sirens that come by right as he's
considering this foreshadowing the crime
scene that he will eventually fall into
uh R.I.P we leave Karen and Ben agreeing
to lay low but continue the work to take
down the king okay so once backavella's
taxi cab service Anatolian Vladimir
stroll in to see their men beaten half
dead with empty bullet shells everywhere
Peter has relayed to Anatoly that
Kingpin is out about and it totally
tells Vladimir that they need Fisk
support clearly the man in Black is
Wayne and they've now officially lost
him three times but Vladimir refuses and
Anatoly goes to Fisk to grovel and we're
back with Vanessa and Fisk and if you
haven't noticed we got four concurrent
stories going on in one episode it's
like the Act One finale of West Side
Story Fisk is gonna crush a skull
tonight
is that the episode where the explosions
happen and then he's like oh embarrass
me so we've got clear keep it and
Vanessa Ben and Karen and then Daredevil
in the middle of it all it's the fourth
episode and they are doing great job
balancing four storylines at once this
lures Vanessa into having zeppa and
gliss an Italian sponge cakey custard
dessert that's normally for children's
parties but he's a big boy he's like
China he's a big boy the lighthearted
date is interrupted by Anatoly he
stumbles in completely ignoring Wesley
and this is a big reveal that 80 of the
men at this restaurant are working for
Wilson Fisk they stand up guns out
prepare to protect that's how important
this man is these goons pretend to have
dinner for him he made it look like it's
a normal date which rightfully unnerves
Vanessa at first but you know deep doubt
she's like she comes back she comes at
first I hated that at first she was like
oh this is a little too much and I was
like girl you are gonna be on top of
this at the end of the like series you
are literally the one orchestrating all
of this do not act like this scares you
you are so into this and also I I think
me and Vanessa are the same person heart
to heart which is so horrible I know I'm
a monster I would have been with Wilson
Fisk either way we come back to Nelson
and Murdoch where Paige shows foggy
their new old fax machine what she
bought at the auction foggy in a
heart-to-heart moment tells Karen his
mom's butcher's story again in a
reversal Matt now patches up Claire this
isn't gonna feel great he tells her a
gentler version of her this is gonna
hurt to him from a previous episode and
like they even mentioned this isn't new
to Matt he's been patching people up
like his dad since he was a child Matt
says I'm just trying to make my city a
better place almost exactly what Fisk
said there are different sides of the
same coin I'll say it once I'll say it
again but I feel like we already kind of
knew this like of course they're the
same person additionally Claire begging
him to tell her it was all for something
he doesn't really have an answer which
is the true essence of street level
grounded vigilantism like you take out
one scum drug lord leader another pops
right back up in his place taking each
criminal one day at a time until you
meet your match sort of like Matt did
with his father and it's interesting
seeing the simple contrast between Karen
and Matt versus Claire and Matt in his
apartment when Karen was there in the
first episode talking about the case and
evidence against her the giant billboard
illuminated white and pink but now that
white can symbolize innocence while
yellow like we see now in this episode
has been linked to optimism and hope
which I think Claire is trying to get
across the mat that he needs to have
hope Matt finally tells Claire his real
name probably because he senses they're
gonna Boone sooner or later and she
should know his real name because he's
finally at a point of trusting her now
that she fully trusts him it's worth
noting that both Matt and Fisk tell
their potential love interests their
first name in this episode again framing
them as similar man with similar
Hang-Ups rarely feeling safe enough to
reveal personal details about themselves
to those around them unfortunately the
awkward date between Fitz and Vanessa is
over this walks through to her apartment
and you see his guards behind them this
is when Vanessa gives him the no-go once
she realizes he might actually be a bad
person and first is burst he's mad
because the date was going smoothly
until Anatoly showed up he's angry and
he needs to take care of this problem
we're in a car with Leslie and Anatoly
and it totally Recaps what happened
between the cab service and Daredevil
you want to talk to piss so they put the
past behind them remember they kept
saying they take on Daredevil and Fisk
handled his end with Braska so someone's
not fulfilling their duties and it ain't
Fisk yeah Wesley says this to Anatoly
they say in the past is etched in stone
but innocent it's
smoke trapped in a closed room swirling
changing the past can never be
completely erased it lingers
like the scent of burning wood if the
last episode was questioning morality
then Wesley literally just summarized
this episode in his monologue the past
could never be escaped and it always
comes back in a different form or place
our perception of it changes Daredevil
is completely driven by his past so is
Kingpin this could be a nod to even
Wesley's Origins but we know Anatolian
Vladimir have been messing up in the
eyes of Fisk then he had the nerve to
ruin that man's date hell no the past
can never be put behind them now it will
keep coming back and they will keep
messing up if there's one major takeaway
from this Fisk never forgets he's like
an elephant this ribs Anatoly out of the
passenger side door and beats the living
crap out of this man it's not even fair
Anatoly didn't get a single hit in just
a single slice of fist suit all of this
because of Vanessa this man has goons
kill for him and he doesn't do his own
dirty work so you know you've messed up
badly to get Kingpin to deliver an ass
whooping like this he also still has
that mentality of a little boy he tells
Anatolia middle beating him up you
embarrassed me in front of her a child a
literal child we see over time how
important Vanessa is to him but this
should be noted for how finicky his
temper can be he'll literally smash your
head in a car door 22 times I counted he
slammed anatoly's head 22 times in the
car door and it would have been more if
he wasn't decapitated on the 22nd one
and you see this all in this episode in
a horrible shot we see blood spray on
Wesley's caller in the dark like this
episode's title we're all in the blood
literally standing in it smothered in it
Pour it onto our shoes into the New York
streets the last thing Vladimir and
Anatoly exchanged before this was a
short argument and it's all sad drop by
drop all of the architecture in Hell's
Kitchen are gonna be covered in blood by
the end of the series that's a promise
that we're seeing delivered on again and
again throughout the series it's just so
incredible they're recreating the
opening title credits I love it and then
Fisk says toe Potter I'll need a new
suit and we'll see Melvin botter on our
road to board again he is the designer
that makes Daredevil suits later in the
show and a well-known figure in the
comics bisque looks at his reflection in
the car window and we know from a later
episode that he's seen himself as a
young boy just after killing his papa
this is what he sees every time he looks
mirror
papa papa no papa no I'm sorry
okay thanks for watching episode 4 of
our road to Born Again Daredevil rewatch
series we'll be back next week for
episode 5 world on fire you didn't
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive I got a Guardians rewatch series I
think you're really gonna like you can
support this growing Network I grabbing
something for our merch store
nerdright.shop subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube on all social
platforms follow Jessica and Lulu
underscore Clemons follow me at EA boss
I'll see you next week bye everybody
[Music]
foreign